la liza minnelli à 50 ans le temps parce
que passe pas sur elle bien sûr et pour
fêter cette décennie et bien il avait
choisi paris le fouquet's et ses amis
dont charles aznavour
nicole candu langlois et ja gregor
étaient de la fête
à 1
m
ils sont venus ils sont tous là pour
fêter les 50 ans de la hyse à l'examiner
lits dont le père d'une chaîne t avait
si bien filmé paris mais ce n'est pas
l'unique raison de son choix pour
célébrer cet événement la vraie
motivation c'est une promesse faite à
charles aznavour il ya longtemps j'avais
connu petite fille grande
inkling et sa vie personnelle et aussi
professionnels
nous sommes plus que les jamie est moins
que des amoureux c'est sa haine des
atchan russe c'est vraiment la meilleure
chose dans une relation
je suis ici parce qu'avec plus c'est que
tout ira bien négocié en avril va me
dire ce que je dois faire pour le reste
de ma vie il l'accompagna donc pour la
remise de la médaille vermeil de paris
par jean tiberi écoute avec ses amis ses
musiciens venus spécialement d'amérique
et chanta pour elle la nostalgie toute
la tendresse d'humour dix ans quand
reviendra à paris pour fêter son
anniversaire
je serai présent à chaque fois comme
d'habitude dire encore
j'avais 20 ans il caressait de temps et
jouer de la vie comme on joue de l'amour
et givet va lui sans compter sur des
joueurs qui fuyait dans le temps j'ai
fait tant de projets qui sont restés en
l'air